you know not too long ago I was saying
we can probably just count down until
the announced cancellation of this
project but guess it's happening
spider-man into the spider verse one of
several trailers to premiere today I'm
doing this one later in the day than
when I did a lead a battle angel I try
not to do more than one video in a day
cuz I don't like flooding people's feeds
but I also need to try and get to these
things in a timely manner Jessica Jones
season 2 I'm gonna do that tomorrow but
for right now this spider-man the Miles
Morales version which I'm glad is coming
to the screen in some form I like Miles
Morales I think that's an interesting
take on it into the spider verse that's
fairly telling and surprising in a lot
of ways it's not something that I would
have thought they would have gone with
although I suppose in some ways it's
there I don't want to say way to placate
but as a way to sort of deal with the
fact that they aren't giving people
Peter Parker is to in some way still
acknowledge hey he's out there somewhere
and the spider verse that might be part
of the thought process I'd like to think
there's probably more narrative meat to
doing spider-verse this way then there
is anything else I'll talk about some of
the narrative possibilities implications
or whatever in a minute I think the
thing I'm trying to figure out my
feelings on is the animation style now
the art style the actual sort of look
that we get which we don't see much of
it's mostly exteriors of a city at night
which looks to be done fairly
realistically and miles himself which we
see mostly in the outfit which looks
good but the movement is weird this is
computer graphics but it's like if
they've animated it trying to make it
look like a like a Studios production
the folks who did
Kubo and the two strings and ParaNorman
it's like they're animating it trying to
make it look like it's stopped action
but it's not which is weird it's weird
to me even when aardman Studios does
that with their computer graphics things
but I don't let them get away with it
because it's in
art-style that they did in in
stop-motion claymation first so I'm kind
fine but it always just strikes me as
weird when you go computer graphics and
deliberately try and make it look like
it was done with a different technique
and it goes beyond just on artistic
style like if that's how you wanted to
look why don't you just animate it in
that technique I mean you know sometimes
it's a practical thing there's a reason
the lego movie was done in a computer
instead of actually moving the LEGO
pieces I get like I get that but at the
same time like there are full-length
feature films using this technique that
look great if you want it to look like
this just do it that way I don't know
it's odd and maybe you could get used to
it and I mean if it works and it is
something I could get used to it's a way
to make the thing stand out be a little
more distinctive because I mean CGI
animation can start to feel a bit samey
if not for these specific artistic
flourishes of any given director studio
what-have-you
so you know I can appreciate the theory
I think but it just strikes me as a
really weird choice so story obviously
there's a teaser we get very little of
this I want to say I'm yeah I wonder how
many people are gonna be disappointing
cuz they know there were a lot of people
well not a lot a lot of people who
comment on my videos have been voicing
some degree of desire to see the
spider-verse done in Sony's films and
that's that's something I don't have a
particularly strong feeling on one way
or the other
I do like spider-man I like Peter Parker
I like a lot of the variants I like
Miles Morales I like Miguel O'Hara I
like you know I like these variant
versions but the actual spider-verse
story wasn't something ever really read
and not something that I particularly
wanted to get into it just seemed this
big sprawling thing and it kind of gave
me like trauma flashbacks to the Clone
Saga and it's just a premise that makes
me nervous
again I've read it maybe it works but I
have to wonder if if there's burning off
spider-verse here if in some ways that's
a statement to say look we're
to win this in the live-action movies if
you want it here you go
that being said I would be impressed if
they were so ballsy as to have it imply
that the spider verse is one of the
other universes is the ones we've
already seen like if we had versions of
spider-man voiced by say Tobey Maguire
Andrew Garfield and get Tom Holland in
there and have them as alternate verses
basically in play like yes this could
spill of like that would that would take
some cojones to do that because it would
imply possibly that Miles Morales could
escape from an animation world into the
real world if they really wanted to go
that direction
I seriously doubt there's any plans to
do that it would be interesting and it
would be gutsy but but other than that
spider verse again sort of strikes me as
probably something to employ as a way to
ease people into Miles Morales a little
bit it's a very open admission like very
upfront in the teaser Peter Parker in
this universe is dead we see the
gravestone and that this is not the only
spider-man there are others out there so
basically without giving you all of
Miles Morales backstory it lays out in
just a trailer a teaser trailer at that
look folks it is okay if the only
spider-man you know is Peter Parker and
you don't aren't familiar with this guy
that's fine he is a different version
that's actually pretty smart as far as
these things go cuz Miles Morales is
pretty well loved by the comic book
readers but I mean to the general public
at large and I keep saying we need the
mainstream unease to come to these
movies otherwise they don't make enough
money for these things to keep being
made they know spider-man is Peter
Parker and that's pretty much it so to
lay out in some degree and make it clear
that this is an alternate version you're
not crazy and we're not changing things
on you there is a Peter Parker out there
but this is just something else that's
it's that's a pretty smart way to
present it so for something that's only
a little over a minute this does a
pretty snappy little job at sort of
setting up the premise largely just
based on the title alone but sort of
getting that out there I get
my main thing is well two main things
this it's a story that you know you get
in parallel dimensions that I've talked
about you know multiverse sort of stuff
it's multiverse narratives aren't they
it's not that they never work they're
not really my thing because I've seen
them go off the rez more often than not
because often the complications that
they add are greater than whatever
narrative value they actually bring but
so I'm iffy about that in the first
place good works though but the
animation style I do have to get used to
that cuz like I said it's not bad
necessarily but I can't quite wrap my
head around it yet so we'll see if that
eases off so this will probably be a
short one I did have thoughts I wanted
to get out there but they're not
especially deep because I mean there
isn't all that much to read into this
it's too short but that's my thought on
spider-man into the spider verse what
are your thoughts on this thing whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about don't forget
to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
that's available on iTunes and stitcher
a podcast they don't call an iTunes
anymore a podcast and stitcher radio I'm
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast that's a presentation of the
fire and water podcast network fire and
water podcasts calm and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]